classic salesperson clothes that  honestly still works today and it's  called the scale in a one to ten close  when you ask someone hey you want to  sign up and they say no you say well on  a scale from one to ten one being i hate  you alex i think your program sucks  you're a terrible person i never want to  see you again to one being this is the  most amazing thing i've ever seen in my  life and i definitely want to sign up  right now today where are you and  they're gonna give you a number let's  say they say six you say cool totally  understand what would it take to get you  to attend just by asking that instead of  giving something that they can walk out  the room with now they have to generate  the reasons and they give you the  ammunition to close